estas tierras bañadas por el río
magdalena han visto mucho sufrimiento
aquí en gamarra una de cada seis
personas han sido víctimas del conflicto
armado colombiano como el exsindicalista
ciro quiroz que lleva toda una vida de
lucha a que gabarra pues
no hemos sido ajenas también al
conflicto armado
y aquí hay un poco más de dos mil
víctimas este municipio
igual que el sur del cesar que también
juega muy atropellado cuando era más
joven peleo por los derechos de los
trabajadores y ahora lo hace por la
memoria como presidente de la mesa de
víctimas local no está un 'falso
positivo'
de joven
es la brigada 15 del ejército lo mataron
en ocaña
y también víctima de la violencia en la
zona en los 90 trabajó como líder es
sindicalista en una empresa de aceite de
palma y fue amenazado por paramilitares
al resistirse a firmar un convenio yo me
intento reintegrar al trabajo
el día que lo hice
en ese preciso día
matan a dos trabajadores en la parcela
por él pero sobre todo por los que
murieron exige verdad el concepto de la
verdad
algo sanador algo que brinda una
satisfacción al ámbito y como muchos
otros en el pueblo ha colaborado con
diferentes organizaciones por la paz
como la comisión de la verdad o la cero
como válida
bien cómo estás bien como famosa víctima
de gabarró creada a partir de los
acuerdos de paz del 2016 la comisión
recogió miles de testimonios de víctimas
y victimarios por más de tres años
ahora tras la publicación de su informe
final recomienda al gobierno colombiano
conseguir la paz con el ln apostará por
la regulación de las drogas y crear un
ministerio de paz tuvo para garantizar
el cumplimiento de los acuerdos algo
fundamental en la región del magdalena
medio marcada por la violencia de
guerrillas como el ln o las farc ep pero
sobre todo de grupos paramilitares que
ha hecho que el trabajo de la comisión
aquí sea todo un viaje
por el dolor por la vida
abrieron su corazón eso algo para contar
más arriba en la ruta fluvial los que
llevan años viviendo en simití han visto
varias masacres paramilitares en este
pueblo campesina y pescador el río es
sinónimo de vida pero también ha sido
testigo de derramamiento de mucha sangre
muchas cosas que se han tenido que ver
sobre todo entre los grupos armados
porque pues uno no es el blanco de ellos
ellos forman su pelotero y en los que
van a pagar son los inocentes en su caso
escapó por poco de una matanza
paramilitar en un restaurante porque por
sobre todas las cosas pues siempre hemos
tratado de echar adelante de pronto esa
heroína
como digo al cuento no dejando vencer
del mal a ella todos los años de
violencia le dejaron un trauma pero
confía en que las cosas cambien y en que
la paz vuelva a las comunidades
ribereñas para que el municipio pueda
celebrar el triunfo de la resiliencia y
dejar atrás todo el dolor
cerca de la orilla del río en
barrancabermeja no todos han dejado
atrás la violencia
alfonso se autodenomina firmante del
acuerdo de paz pero tiene que llevar un
chaleco antibalas siempre que está en la
ciudad y hoy las residencias de las farc
pues con ellos
no puede salir el que una vez fue
comandante de las farc ep es ahora
víctima por defender la construcción de
la paz y las recomendaciones de la
comisión de la verdad para nosotros
significa algo muy importante
significa una garantía de la
implementación del acuerdo de paz porque
como dice la consigna sin verdad no hay
futuro una de las consignas que vertebra
la comisión de la verdad desde donde
esperan que tras el fin de su mandato
las víctimas logran justicia la fuerza
que ellos han puesto ha hecho posible el
acuerdo y ha hecho posible que podamos
juntos tejer un mejor futuro mientras
ellas se esperan cerrar este capítulo de
una vez por todas y contar con el apoyo
del gobierno es algo grande para
nosotros creíamos que era en aquel
tiempo estábamos solos hoy en día vemos
que en realmente no estamos orden un
viaje a la verdad que todavía no ha
terminado y que depende del trabajo
conjunto de las víctimas victimarios
y de todos los colombianos